all right Brit Brit uh where'd you grow
up where you from originally I grew up
in the suburbs right outside San
Francisco uh Daily City San Bruno South
San Francisco what was your childhood
life uh it was good uh parents stayed
together um I was the oldest of uh I was
the oldest of four uh had two brothers
and a
sister family you got along with your
mom and dad yeah but I was yeah I kind
of ramb bux just kind of a
kind of a punk but I got along with them
dad worked really hard uh plastered
swimming pools so so he was cat Mason
what kind of kid were you in high school
um I wasn't good in high school I
dropped out of high school in ninth
grade are you a troublemaker yes hung
around older guys hung around a lot of
tough guys my dad was like a tough guy
like a legitimate tough guy growing up
uh kind of just rubbed off and then I
started hanging around guys that were
older than me um not in school so I
ended up dropping
out and how'd you get into law
enforcement with that background I
wasn't even thinking about it never
thought I'd be a cop um when I dropped
out of school I I was a garbage man um I
installed Windows as a Glazer Union
Glazer uh worked for the Teamsters Local
85 loading
trucks um just did jobs like that and
then uh I started getting in my with my
dad and uncle swimming pool construction
they were pull plasters so they were
Masons so uh I started working with them
and uh got married early uh
22 got married at 22 uh
so by then I had two daughters I have
three daughters total I had two
daughters and
uh money wasn't good it was feast or
famine money good one month no money the
next so cuz the weather and rain and
this and that all the conditions would
throw you off so uh my buddy was a San
Francisco fireman and he told me he was
older than me and he told me dude you
got to get a job in the city you got to
get a job for one of the Cities doing
anything so uh I went back and got my
GED I really didn't go back to get my
GED I went back and took my GED test and
I passed it so they had to give me my G
uh GED so uh that was when I was about
24 uh started applying for uh Fire
Department jobs police jobs uh I ended
up getting picked up by SEL Sheriff's
Office as a correctional officer in the
jail
um wasn't really into getting the job at
first because uh didn't think that's
what I wanted to do but it had benefits
um me and my wife were paying our own uh
medical bills for the babies being born
and stuff and it was expensive so this
gave me benefits healthare care uh
vacation gave me all the stuff I needed
um owed it to my wife to do it so uh did
that um kind of crazy at first I went
there uh went to the my first day at the
jail they were moving into a new jail
and they put me up at uh 3 West it was
like murder Max where all the murder
murderers are so my first day
there there's a young group of black
young kids but they were of age they
were they were in their
20s High Teens and uh they were in for
all kinds of murders and uh they started
giving me they started like
when you turn your back
I'mma kill you I'mma stick a
knife in you and I was like son of a
so I went home and was like
this is going to be like this every day
so the next day I go back to 3
West and they're all laughing at me and
they were like we scared the out of
you and I was like no you didn't and
they're like like yeah we did we scared
the out of you and they were just
they were just playing with me um I
worked in the jail for three and A2
years uh got along with the inmates
there because I kind of grew up around
all those guys so so I was I was around
people that that were going to jail so
it wasn't a wasn't a big thing for me so
uh I respected them they respected me um
it was good but uh I wanted to go out to
the street so I took uh took the has to
go to San Francisco police and I got
picked up by them in
1997 you were
hold I went into the sheriff's office
when I was I think
27 and I went to uh I went to sfpd San
Francisco police department when I was
32 32 how long you been doing it um
since then I've been there uh 20 I'm
going on my 26th year right now with San
Francisco police currently you're an
undercover narcotics detective yeah I um
I've been pretty lucky in my career I
only worked for about a year in
uniform and um I was working out of it's
a district called Engleside
station I worked out of there um I went
through my training and then I went
there for probation but uh immediately I
got picked up and started working plain
clothes and a plain clothes unit there
so I didn't really have a uniform on for
that long and uh I would kind of mesh
with the narcotics guys they would come
through and I worked the projects down
there in Engleside so they would come
through and be doing search warrants and
and buy bust you know like uh drug rips
and stuff so I would uh I would talk to
them and they I kind of clicked with
them so uh they asked me do you want to
come to narcotics so I was like sure if
I can go I'd go so uh in 1999 end of
1999 I got transferred for 6 months up
to narcotics so I went up to the
narcotics unit and I've been there since
I've been there like 23 2 4 years at the
you're active still but I'm going to I'm
recording this in the winter of
but you're retiring later this year and
yeah I'll retire by the end of the year
I'll have uh 27 years
in 26 27 years here and I'll have uh
three and a half with the sheriff's
office so I'll pretty much be a full
pension yeah and you asked me to wait
until you retire to expose your identity
yes please so you've got some crazy
stories I know from this work yeah so I
go to the narcotics unit and uh because
I'm new and I'm young uh they tell me
you're going to buy dope so uh my whole
thing was uh I got put on a buy bus team
where I would dress up with others we'd
dress up like kind of disheveled kind of
bum and we'd walk through the tenderloin
and we would purchase back then it was
crack crack was the big thing back then
so uh we purchase crack all day and I
would go in and purchase it I'd give a
signal that I had just engaged in a in a
a Narcotics buy and the arrest team
would come in and make the
arrest so uh back in the day when it was
crack they uh um they would keep it in
their mouths wrapped in plastic so they
would uh they would tell you to open
your mouth so they can pull it out of
their mouth and throw it in yours
because they wanted to test you to see
if you're a cop so a lot of the officers
didn't want to do that and then I
started kicking it around I was like
well
I got to get the arrest I want to arrest
these guys CU I mean that was my big
thing was putting people in jail so uh I
would be like go ahead throw it in my
mouth so I'd do like the 3se second roll
man I'd try to get it out right away
when they when they tossed it in my
mouth but uh we did that for we did that
for years during the crack era a lot of
the crack dealers will put the crack
they they'll hold their stash in their
mouth hold their stash in their mouth
and then if the cops come up they'll
drink water they'll swallow it and
that's the that's the terrible thing cuz
they it out clean it up and then
they put it back in their mouth and then
they're putting it into your mouth so
but uh back then I was I was I was
jacked that I was doing that so I didn't
care I was like bring it on what is the
attraction to this is is it are you an
adrenaline
junkie that's probably my only that's
probably my only adrenaline is is doing
this is uh you know acting out uh as a
bum or a crook or a drug dealer or
something something that that uh I get a
real high out of it um because I'm in
there by myself I'm dealing with it by
myself I I do uh I get a big uh big lift
out of that yeah you're dealing with
some of the most dangerous people yes in
the country yeah yeah what kind of stuff
I mean it's not just drugs too right no
buy a lot of guns um what happened was
so I I worked in the narcotics unit
doing bu bust and I was put on a uh it
was a HUD Task Force Team it was federal
and state and we did just the projects
that was a lot of fun we would just go
through and uh hit all the housing units
that were dealing drugs or guns and then
when 911 hit they defunk that group so
the all money went into FBI for
terrorism so that's when uh we went back
out on the street just doing regular we
all kind of had our little glitch of the
of the kind of drugs we would deal with
and who we would work with um and then
in
2005 uh the chief sent me and a couple
guys up to DEA and I work up there as a
task force officer until present I'm
still up there and a task force officer
is uh I'm uh I swear into federal powers
as well as state so I can arrest
federally or I can arrest State and I
can do both and uh my main thing that I
went up there was because I was doing a
lot of uh undercover buys for um for DEA
so DEA had me come up there and I work
uh on a Metro task force it's called and
uh we do everything from Street uh from
Street enforcement all the way up to uh
T3 wir Taps so we work towards wir Taps
and uh once I got up there I started
doing buys for
ATF um
HSI um
DEA you name it uh they call me up and
they ask uh if I'll uh if I'll uh be uh
you see the undercover for uh for their
cases you showed me some of your videos
that you shot while you're undercover
and they're the most convincing things
I've ever seen of there's no way the guy
who's selling guns wouldn't buy you as
legit I mean you guys look like you and
your partner look like thugs yeah yeah
and I mean I get I get an enjoyment out
of that
um kind of tricking them thinking that
uh you know I'm coming in to buy guns
because I move guns or um the big thing
I do is I work kind of like U I tell
them I don't use I tell them either
getting test it because I just got out
of uh the pen or that I'm getting tested
cuz I got a good job now and uh they
test all the time like I got a
mechanical job where they're always
testing that's a union job so I tell
them I'm a hook and a hook is somebody
who goes in and uh a hook will be
somebody that like I'll buy dope I'll
buy guns I'll buy stolen items and I'll
make some money off them so it's pretty
common that you know like I look for a
plug and a plug is somebody that can
provide me dope or guns or something so
I find a plug I tell them I'm a hook I
just making money off the stuff give it
to me cheap so I can make some money off
it and I can move a lot of it and uh
they buy into
that how does this affect your personal
life are you still married oh yeah uh
your wife understands yeah totally
totally yeah she does I got I got uh
three daughters they're all grown up uh
two of my son-in-laws are San Francisco
police officers as well uh my other
son-in-law works for a big college in uh
uh paloalto major college as a
Construction Group supervisor um I got
seven
grandkids uh yeah my wife's been my
wife's the best she's the best you live
a great life yeah it is an exciting one
it
is yeah what the hairiest thing you've
gotten into in your
career um usually when I get in a car
with somebody get in their car and they
got a gun on them
um they're not
the everybody's so Macho you know
everybody has so uh you'll you'll get in
arguments you'll get arguments over
prices and stuff like that and
uh something can happen pretty quick so
that's probably
the that's probably the thing is you're
by yourself if somebody was to come help
you it' pretty much be too late uh if
rescue came in to to rescue me um so
it's it's that little I get a big rise
out that little you know five minutes of
something could go wrong you know
here
um I've done
like I worked on a big case in 2017
where it was a fencing
operation um
ATF DEA San Francisco police um Daily
City police um they uh CHP CHP was
involved they had a warehouse just
outside of San Francisco and I worked as
a a fencer and uh I was buying guns dope
and stolen cars
and uh they would call me um and I would
uh they would bring them through the
warehouse and I would purchase it and it
would be all on camera and stuff and we
did that for about a year that was that
was a lot of fun um I dealt with a lot
of different people uh a lot of
different drugs a lot of stolen cars a
lot of uh rifles a lot of high-powered
rifles and pistols we had a lot of fun
doing that I think we arrested
probably I think about 115 people by the
time it was over uh some went Federal
some went
State um I've just worked some really
good cases like some of the cases that I
work will be like eight-month long cases
where uh I'll hook in with a a a guy
trafficking firearms and I'll work like
for eight months just buying from him
periodically and gaining more
information and they build a bigger case
and uh we've worked on a I've worked on
a lot of cases where I'll go down here
in the tenderloin and I'll
purchase and uh we'll work on a wire
we'll work on a wire tap like building
its way up to a wire tap and we'll end
up uh with uh sources out of Mexico you
know like every step we'll take we'll
just go up the ladder to a bigger Source
a bigger Source just based off of that
that one person settling down in the
tender line are you making a dent in the
crime that goes on in this country
before you answer that is I think is
getting worse you've been doing this
long enough to it's getting worse it's
it's getting worse yeah it's getting
worse I think because of the laws and
stuff yeah they seem to be allowing a
lot of like like just yesterday last
night all my equipment got stolen down
here that's so common the second time
I've been robbed in San Francisco yeah
it's so common right now and it's the
the laws I think and they're not holding
anybody in jail right now are you making
a dent in all of
this would like to think I am but I
don't think so you don't um I mean
fentanyl over the last five years is is
the the that's the latest craze and it's
out of control yeah it's out of control
compared to any other drug right now we
thought we had a crack ERA this
fentanyls surpassed it by
far it's so much more destructive oh
it's it's poison just kills it it's
poison it's it's totally different than
any other drug it's it's it's really
you're when you do
Fentanyl you're playing with death
because it slows your it slows your
breathing down and it can slow it down
to where it's stops I mean we run
probably I mean we probably
run well well we're run an average of
600 deaths uh of
overdoses um about 80% of them are in
the tenderloin fentanyl all fent all
related 600 per per year per year
yeah
yeah what do you think the solution
might be stricter
laws stricter laws in uh it's hard cuz
we're a sanctuary City so nobody goes
back home you know I don't really have
opinion on it either way but nobody goes
back home so you could break the law all
you want and and nobody gets sent to
their room you
know
um yeah it's it's it's not good it's not
good but I mean I enjoy what I'm doing
um I enjoy putting good Crooks in jail
you know it's it's it's uh it's more
rewarding working with the feds because
uh you work with the federal system
they're going away for 5 10 15 20 years
you know you're very interesting I'm
sorry to interrupt you're very
interesting because you could have gone
the other way absolutely and somehow
miraculous that you chose to go on this
side of the law yes well I didn't really
choose it it was weird it just like
became my path and then I went
from I never thought about being a
police officer okay to being a corre
officer working in a jail and then I get
out to San Francisco and I think okay
I'm just going to be a uniform cop
working on the street and within six
months I'm wearing plain clothes working
that district and six eight months after
that I'm up at narcotics buying dope you
know it's like a dream job is there is
there a real is there a big difference
between the bad guys and the good guys
no there's really not I mean I respect
them I see good in every everybody
um probably the biggest difference
is they're lazy they want the easy route
they want the easy way out to make money
everybody wants to doesn't want to put A
Hard Day's Work in everyone wants a
quick lick that's what they want they
want to make that quick money and and
it's all
because they're driving nice cars
they're wearing nice
clothes they're it's not going to their
families they're not spending a lot on
their families they're not trying
to raise themselves out of
uh the problems they have they just it's
all Flash and they're not being good
role models to their kids absolutely not
you know so the kids are just going to
repeat it yeah it becomes a vicious
cycle and uh it's it's uh the
money's the money's not going anywhere
it's it's just it's rolling in their
cars and clothes and watches and and um
it's not uh and that's what that's with
all the drug dealers I mean it's that
quick Buck everybody's trying to make
you know and uh I've had informant that
work for I run a lot of informants I've
had informant that I've I've gotten them
good jobs you know I want to get out of
this they might last maybe a month and
they're like N I got to get up in the
morning and work you know no I a't going
to do that you know I'm gonna go right
back to what I was doing what's your
biggest fear for for our country for
Society for yourself for this
city it's just I mean it's I just hope
San Francisco doesn't implode you know I
hope it doesn't
um I mean you've been through the
tenderloin it's it's unreal yeah it
seems a little more out of control here
than even skid row no it's it's it's a
it's a bigger skid row it's eight blocks
by eight blocks of skid row it's almost
like the whole city of San Francisco has
something going on absolutely it's a
little dark ER than what goes on in La
it doesn't get addressed here I'm not
political at all but even in our world
right now nobody talks about fentanyl
how bad it is you know the higher ups
they don't talk about it I don't know
what's going to happen but in the
tenderloin in the last 52 weeks just
uniform and just arrest in the
tenderloin that was 141 PBS of fentanyl
seized 141 PBS 141 PBS and that's just
Street stuff it's not talking about
going to anybody's houses or anything
where's it all coming from Mexico that's
a good thing like with the feds we uh up
at DEA we work on wir Taps we'll chase
the drugs all the way back to the Border
we'll go right up that ladder and you
know the street dealer then the
mid-level dealer then the larger dealer
the major vendor and then we'll push all
the way into cartels I deal with the
cartels on U buys I do I've had cases
where I've purchased narcotics and I'm
talking to somebody in Mexico while
doing the deals over the phone shipping
the money out to Mexico through a wiring
it over there and uh getting dope here
from the street level to Mexico there's
not a lot in between it's it's pretty
close pretty quick and the Mexicans are
Relentless they're just shipping it in
it and it just gets cheaper and it gets
cheaper I mean when I was purchasing
methamphetamine back in
2005 I paying 14,000 a pound for it I
could buy a pound I could buy a pound
wholesale from a trafficker that I'm
dealing
with we've got it as we got it as as
cheap as 800 bucks now from $4,000 down
to $800 now for a pound of meth
99% 99%
pure you find your tolerance or your
appetite for danger has increased over
the years it's always been the same I
just I enjoy it I enjoy that uh that
risk it's probably not healthy yeah I
got the same
problem people uh people like guys that
are my age ask me dude why are you going
to stop you know why are you going to
stop doing all the undercover work and
stuff and as long as I'm working for the
Department I can't I mean unless they
made me but other than that I uh that's
I enjoy it do you feel like your dad was
a big had a big impact in who you became
workwhite he had a strong work ethic he
he has a strong work ethic and and I
think that was instilled in me
but he was also in the
streets no he wasn't on the streets no
he was not not not on the streets but he
was he was dealing with those kind of
guys no not really he uh um he was a
cement Mason and just he's just like a
just a tough dude just a tough guy oh I
see I yeah he was just a tough guy you
mentioned that earlier yeah and uh no no
drugs nothing like that in our
family um I don't drink or smoke um I
did when I was younger I haven't drank
and smoke in 30 years um wife doesn't
drink or smoke my kids have been perfect
you know I had no issues at all hadn't
had any issues um wife did a great job
raising them
um I was working all the time so she she
really took care of it it's
great um it's nice to hear somebody with
a great family yeah my daughters are
dispatchers so everybody was kind of
tied to law enforcement and it didn't
happen until I I became involved in law
enforcement
if you had your life to live all over
again would you have done anything
differently I'll we got involved in a
good job sooner instead of struggling
for so long um you would have started
with this kind of work
earlier if I what I know now yes yes I
would have and like I've never I just
tested recently for a Sergeant's
position because I was getting ready to
leave but I never uh I never wanted to
be I just wanted to be an officer I just
want to work the streets there guys that
have done your kind of work and have
lost their lives yeah yeah do you feel
like you're somehow protected or
somebody's watching over you
or that or maybe that or Tombstone
courage or something I don't know I
don't know but I just I just get a I get
a rush out of it um I think I gel well
with people that I'm dealing with when
I'm working undercover
because I grew up around those guys
you're pretty in I could see you being
very convincing as a as a th I grew up
around him and uh I mean I build
relationships with him it's kind of
weird when it's over like I'll deal with
a guy for a year and then when they take
him down they'll be like you know no
he's not a cop they'll be like he's a
cop they'll be like no there's no way
he's a cop you know some of them get
very offended that I got involved in
their world and they trusted me and some
of them don't some of them are like hey
let me meet them again you know I want
to meet him and some of them work for us
you know some of them are like dude you
you've convinced me I I can take you out
and convince other people so they can
they can downward depart their the time
they do in jail do you think a lot of
these people that are on the wrong side
of the law
are can can be re
rehabilitated
no only reason I say that is because of
the money I mean These Guys these guys
selling right now in the tender line as
we speak they're making ,500 a
day you make 1,500 a day you're not
going to want
to do manual
labor to to make a 100 or 200 a day it's
not you're not going to do
it you know it's just I think they get
the bit by the bug and they that's why
they go back to what they
do you know it's like it's like a bank
robber that we say if you put a if a
bank robber gets out of jail he's going
to be your first suspect when a bank
gets rubbed cuz that's what they know
what to do that's that's how they that's
how they survive what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life seeing all this Darkness
it's got to give you a unique
perspective I mean one of the things is
to sit back and
really think about things I mean
everybody rushes so quick and gets
involved so fast especially you know
when they're when they're doing wrong
things they don't kind of like think
about it I mean you turn around sell
dope and then I come in into your world
and I get you arrested you got to pay
for lawyers you got to go to jail you go
right back to zero and then when you get
back out you got to start again and and
you're not going to start again very
rarely will you start again on the right
path you know it's
uh it's it's it's a bad
cycle but uh I feel
like I mean I enjoy putting them in jail
uh but I also I also respect them and
understand they do why they do what they
do I don't think it's right that helps
you know the fact you can understand the
whole situation yeah I don't think it's
right but I know why what they're doing
I don't I never came into this
profession hating them because they're
Crooks no not at all I grew up around
them so I see what they why they do it
and I think a lot of it's Laz and don't
want to put the effort in on
something and want the fast buck
but
uh I don't know um what else have I
done I've gone in jails before dressed
as
inmates um I was in a jail cell for five
hours with a a gang member and uh he
talked to me about um a murder he
committed and I got him to to talk about
it thinking that you were another
prisoner he thought I was was from State
Prison
yeah and he thought I was from state
prison so he talked to me about it and
uh I was wired up with the wire on but I
was wearing jail they brought me in I
was wearing jail clothes in the
cell eating peanut butter sandwiches and
apples with him and uh he came around
and started talking about
it I thought that to me was
accomplishment I want to see if I can
get him to to do it he
did I want to see if I can get that buy
on the street or if I can jump in this
guy's car and get him to sell me a gun
or if I can go into a jail cell and get
him to talk to me it's a challenge
little
challenges all right Brit thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you I
wish you the best of luck all right
thank you after you retired all
right